جاءت انتخابات 2020 وذهبت وكان
الرئيس ترامب يلمح إلى أنه
يمكن أن يعود في عام 2024.
حتى مع إصراره على أنه لم يخسر
انتخابات 2020 ورفض التنازل عن
الرئيس المنتخب جو بايدن
، ألمح الرئيس ترامب إلى
نيته وفعل ذلك.  لذلك بالنسبة لمجموعة من
الجمهوريين
في حدث عيد الميلاد في البيت الأبيض هذا
الأسبوع
، كانت أربع سنوات رائعة ونحن
نحاول قضاء أربع سنوات
أخرى بخلاف ذلك
[موسيقى]
عادةً عندما يفقد شاغل المنصب
الناخبين ويحول الدعم
إلى المرشحين الذين لديهم أفضل  بالصدفة ،
لكن ترامب أثبت مرارًا وتكرارًا أنه
يجد دائمًا طريقة للبقاء
في دائرة الضوء تمكنه من جمع
الأموال في هذه الحالة ،
لذا يمكن إجراء حملة عودة
يتضح أنها تمت بنجاح
مرة واحدة منذ ما يقرب من 128 عامًا
مع الرئيس غروفر كليفلاند الثاني والعشرون
والرئيس الرابع والعشرون
هو أيضًا بعد أن خسر محاولته لإعادة
انتخابه في عام 1889 ،
غادر البيت الأبيض بالفعل مع
تطلعات للعودة
بعد أربع سنوات لينضم إلي الآن  cuss
هو البروفيسور
مايكل غيرهارت أستاذ
القانون الدستوري المتميز في
جامعة نورث كارولينا
كتب عن كليفلاند والقادة العامين الآخرين
في فترة ولاية واحدة
في كتابه الرؤساء المنسيون الذين
ستتذكرون أنه أدلى بشهادته
قبل عام أمس أمام المنزل
لصالح محاكمة الرئيس ترامب ،
لذا فإن الأستاذ
هو النموذج هنا أقرب إلى غروفر
كليفلاند
أو أقرب إليك ، يصحح لي فان
بيورن فيلمور ويعطي
حسنًا هذا سؤال رائع
وأعتقد
أننا لا نعرف الإجابة بعد أه مع فان
بيورن من
أجل  على سبيل المثال ، لقد كان رئيسًا لولاية واحدة
فقط حاول عدة مرات العودة لكنه
كان قادرًا فقط على العودة
كمرشح طرف ثالث لم يقترب أبدًا من
أي شيء
فيما يتعلق بالمنح الذي كان يفكر
في الذهاب لثالث  مصطلح
متردد لم يحاول العودة
وبحلول ذلك الوقت كان قد فات الأوان وارتبطت إدارته
بقدر كبير من الفساد
بقدر ما
يتعلق الأمر بجروفر كليفلاند.
نعلم
أننا نعرف ما يكفي حتى الآن لنقول إن الرئيس
ترامب يمكن أن يكون مثل كليفلاند
كليفلاند قد فاز بأغلبية أو
أغلبية الأصوات الشعبية ثلاث
مرات متتالية
وهذا ليس شيئًا
فعله الرئيس ترامب
مرة واحدة وبعد ذلك حافظ الرئيس كليفلاند
على سيطرة محكمة للغاية على
الديمقراطية  الحزب بين فترتيه
وما زلنا لم نرى ما إذا كان
الرئيس ترامب يمكنه فعل ذلك أم لا
، ثم أخيرًا وليس آخرًا ، تمتع كليفلاند
بسمعة طيبة في الصدق والنزاهة
وكان ذلك أحد الأشياء التي
أحبها الناخبون فيه وأعتقد
أنني  سيقول أن معظم الأمريكيين لا يجدون
نفس الصفة في الرئيس الحالي